[Música]
después de dos años de ausencia y
confinamientos el carnaval de río de
janeiro regresa este fin de semana y
promete un frenesí de plumas carrozas y
piel
momentos fue mucho tiempo esperando que
llegara este día todos estamos deseando
que llegue somos cosas
[Música]
quiero que todos se apure está tardando
demasiado la vida se trata de alegría no
de tristezas
no es posible definir lo que sentimos
porque llevamos dos años conteniendo
nuestras soluciones esperando ojalá
estemos bien hidratados y ya que habrá
lágrimas de las pasarelas
envueltos en lentejuelas miles de
bailarines de la ciudad buscan llegar al
sambódromo el icónico lugar del desfile
que el año pasado se convirtió en un
centro de vacunación contra el kobe 19 y
se espera que sea una competencia reñida
entre las escuelas de samba el carnaval
se realiza bajo unas reglas estrictas y
tradicionales ante los jueces cada
escuela tiene hasta 70 minutos para
contar una historia a través de la
música y el baile la ciudad exige que
todos los participantes y asistentes
estén completamente vacunados y no habrá
blocos las grandes fiestas callejeras
que acompañan el desfile después de los
temores de un aumento de coronavirus el
evento se pospuso dos meses este año
luego de su cancelación en 2020 y 2021
cuando la pandemia asoló a brasil el
número total de muertes de país por el
coronavirus es superado sólo por eeuu